So as the networks were calling the presidential
election for Joe Biden on Saturday morning,
Donald Trump was golfing and announcing a
major press conference about voter fraud
at Four Seasons in Philadelphia. Now, of course,
people thought Trump he loves, you know, luxurious
places. He must be talking about the luxurious and
swanky Four Seasons Hotel in Philadelphia. But no,
Donald Trump clarified the event would be at Four
Seasons, total landscape in Philadelphia. I'm sure
it's a great business, but it's just a random
landscaping business in Philadelphia, sandwiched
between a crematorium and a porn store and buy
a lawyer's press conference. He was using the
term a little loosely. He met Rudy Giuliani. Rudy
Giuliani completely humiliated himself, continuing
to make all sorts of bogus allegations. And then
during the event, a reporter actually tells him,
hey, the race has been called for Joe Biden.
And here's how Rudy Giuliani reacts to the poll,
because they don't feel the call for Joe Biden,
who was a call by all the oh, my
goodness. All the networks. Wow.
All the networks. We have to forget about the law.
Judges don't count all the networks, all the
networks. Well, the networks thought Biden was
going to win by 10 percent. Gee, what happened?
Come on. Don't be don't be ridiculous. Networks
don't get to decide elections. Courts do.
This is, of course, rude being Rudy. But
there's an important topic in there, which is the
idea of not giving courts a chance to weigh in,
as if calling an election before courts have had a
say is wrong. Remember, the election is not being
called by networks in an official capacity.
Networks decide. Looking at data,
does the other candidates still have a path?
And networks have made the call that Donald Trump
doesn't have a path. Nothing is official until
states certify their elections and they still
have days to do that. So even the premise
that networks have made official calls,
you have to understand what that even means. But
the people talking about Lessa courts haven't had
a say yet. This is like when I get emails from,
unfortunately, delusional viewers who say, David,
please cover that. I've sued Mark Zuckerberg
and we're waiting for judges to tell me how
much money Zach Owen owes me because he spied on
me. It's not happening. It's just delusional. The
concept of letting it play out is a joke.
Joe Biden got more votes in enough states
to get 270 electoral votes. There's no credible
evidence of fraud that's been presented. Courts
have thrown out all of the appeals that have been
made so far. There's no reason for courts to get
involved. They're pretending that the default is
until courts weigh in on each state's election.
We don't really have the ability to say who
won this thing. Courts have nothing to weigh
in on right now. They've dismissed every bogus
complaint from the Trump campaign so far. So
we don't have to wait for courts. Now, here's one
more clip. This is more of a wide shot. So you can
see the entire scene at the landscaping shop.
They put Rudy Giuliani's lectern in front of
the garage door at the landscaping
shop. And here is Rudy ranting.
Even when a court order was obtained to the
House, the Republicans expect inspectors to get
six feet closer. They move people counting
the ballots six further feet away.
It's really simple. If you have nothing to
hide with these ballots, allow inspection.
I mean, this is common knowledge, common practice
and the examination of absentee
ballots, which happens all the time.
The phrase total, complete, total and complete
humiliation really doesn't do justice to
the fiasco that was this event, the tragic
descent of Rudy Giuliani, from New York mayor
to kooky guy yelling at clouds about voter
fraud in the parking lot of a Philadelphia
landscaping company. What a bizarre year that it
has been. And reports, as I mentioned earlier,
are that Rudy is encouraging Donald Trump to
hold rallies nationwide, demanding recounts.
I actually hope Trump takes Rudy's advice
because it would just be hilarious.